j'ai oublié la deuxième bande
elle est ici
et voilà
[Musique]
je m'appelle Isabelle choco
je suis né à
une ville textile en Pologne
j'ai été
déporté et enfermer à Orchies
toute la famille a été tuée
je suis la seule rescapée
[Musique]
ma mère et mon père était des parents
très aimants
ils avaient qu'une seule fille et ils
étaient pas très jeunes
ils avaient une fille qui les aimait
beaucoup et qui leur donnait pas mal de
joie avec de bonnes notes de l'école
[Musique]
très dur
on avait des rations pour manger très
petites qui nous laissait la fin après
avoir mangé notre petit bout de pain
qu'on le savait le matin et puis une
petite soupe midi
on avait fait tout le temps les
Allemands nous ont obligé
de mettre les étoiles juives
devant une et derrière l'autre si on
aura
pour qu'on puisse reconnaître les Juifs
même des dos
c'est prisonnier français
il a compris que j'ai parlé un peu les
Français et donc il s'est arrêté à côté
de moi et il me parlait en ayant la tête
baissée pour que on l'entende pas que
seulement moi je puisse l'entendre et
c'est lui qui m'a dit attention jeune
fille attention tu vois
moi il y avait le train qui nous amenait
ensuite
à gauche quand tu descendras c'est la
vie à droite c'est la mort alors
n'oublie pas
quand tu descendras du train tu vas à
gauche
tu vas
moi je me suis dit oui moi je vais à
gauche et ma mère comment je fais pour
amener ma mère
peut pas partir toute seule
j'ai réussi
à diriger ma mère avec moi
elle était toujours derrière moi
et moi
j'étais heureuse de pouvoir
me faire suivre par ma mère
[Musique]
mais ma mère
elle m'a toujours suivi
tout le temps tout le temps
et quand on écoutait couché par terre
elle était par terre à côté de moi
elle était à côté de moi
et
ensuite
arrêter avec moi à bergenbergson
dans ce camp où il n'y avait rien à
manger j'avais 11 ans au commencement
et j'avais
16 ans et demi et 7 ans à la fin
j'ai été libéré à
au 3/4 mortes
par terre
je n'ouvrais presque plus les yeux
ma mère était dans mes bras
elle est décédée
malheureusement
avant l'arrivée des Anglais qui nous ont
libéré
je m'en suis jamais remise
voilà
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup travaillé quand je suis
arrivé en France
et un jour
j'ai vu
un jeu d'échec
je me suis rappelé
qu'augietto j'avais appris un jour
échecs
et avec quelqu'un
qui connaissait les jeux de chèques
il a apporté les jeux d'échec
pour moi
et puis moi j'ai pu le mettre le jeu
d'échec comme je l'ai mis ici sur la
table
j'ai joué d'abord dans un cercle
où j'étais simple joueuse échec
et puis petit à petit
Omar
et puis
il y avait donc tarte à
l'ancien champion qui m'a remarqué et
qui lui voulait que je sois championne
et donc
avec son aide avec son travail à lui
je tue apprendre vraiment bien un jour
si vous voulez jouer avec moi vous
verrez
[Musique]
comment était l'atmosphère
d'abord les tournois d'échec étaient
masculin alors quand on me voyait moi on
m'a envoyé
de côté en disant qu'est-ce qu'elle
fiche celle-là ici j'étais la seule
femme
alors j'aimais vous dire que c'était un
peu la rigolade de la part des hommes
regardez-moi cela
gardez comment elle s'habille
regardez-moi cette femme
il s'est manqué de moi vraiment
en se disant une femme qui joue aux
échecs qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
j'étais un animal curieux pour
moi j'étais tranquille
il pouvait faire il pouvait dire ce
qu'il voulait
moi j'avais maître tarte à Corvair qui
m'a choisi donc c'est bon
et puis
quand ils ont joué avec moi ils allaient
se promener
oui mais quand il revenait ils étaient
chez Kate
et voilà
des surprises alors là ils ont compris
que le femme pouvait aussi jouer aux
échecs
[Musique]
elle faisait pas la une de journaux à ce
moment-là c'est moi qui faisait la une
des journaux
alors
ça m'a beaucoup amusé parce que
Marilyn Monroe je la connaissais bien
sûr comme tout le monde
être comparé à Marilyn Monroe
moi je trouvais pas que c'était un
compliment pour moi
l'échecs m'ont préparé pour la vie dans
ce sens que il faut se battre pour
gagner ça oblige à avoir
une notion d'avenir est-ce qu'il va se
passer oh le message pour les jeunes il
est toujours dans ma tête
en disant
qu'il s'intéresse
à ce qui les entoure qu'il s'intéresse à
la vie
qu'il
fasse
ce qu'ils peuvent pour rendre leur vie
intéressantes pour le même des gens et
pour les autres ensuite
et quel âge avez-vous
[Musique]
je dis pas mon âge